morning all he has been away from the
spotlight since losing the presidential
election
but last night donald trump was back
with a bang
and a big hint that he may consider
running for president
in 2024 and what was his first major
address since leaving office
he launched a number of scathing attacks
on president biden
and repeated those false claims that
last year's presidential election
was rigged uh aleister bunkel reports
now
from orlando in florida
[Music]
it is 39 days since we last heard from
donald trump
and boy have his supporters missed it
the former president has had five and a
half weeks to stew on defeat
and consider his future he might have
left the white house
but he isn't leaving politics biden has
failed in his number one duty as chief
executive
enforcing america's laws
this alone should be reason enough for
democrats to suffer withering losses in
the
midterms and to lose the white house
decisively four years from now
actually as you know they just lost the
white house but it's one of those things
but who knows who knows
i may even decide to beat them for a
third time
okay
trump had points to make scores to
settle
and old missed truth to pedal we have a
very sick
and corrupt electoral process that must
be
fixed immediately this election was
rigged and the supreme court and other
courts
didn't want to do anything about it
by writes after losing the election by
seven million votes
and having been impeached for a second
time trump's political career
should be dead and buried but it's not
just look at this
in the end he took his supporters right
to the edge but stopped
just short of announcing his candidacy
in 2024
but what is clear is that the republican
party
is still trump's party and anybody who
got in his way
will be made to pay for it trump's
supporters
are galvanized by a misplaced sense of
injustice
and it works in his favor it was all
love it was all
it was like the best time i've had in
months yeah
yeah he's the greatest president we've
ever had i'm inspired
recharged our batteries you're ready to
go take on the battle and finish what
president trump started
will he run in 2024 what do you reckon
you really are asking that question
i hope to see him before that he's
running
trump is playing the game and making
sure that he stays
relevant he's kept his supporters
waiting and america guessing
but it felt like the 2024 election
campaign started
in florida last night alice debunker sky
news
orlando
a hunt is underway for a person believed
to be infected with the brazilian
variant of concern after six cases were
confirmed
confirmed in the uk uh known as p1
the variant shares key mutations with
that found in south africa
still to be established if the variant
makes vaccines less effective there are
currently six known cases of the variant
in the uk
three in the grampian region of scotland
two
in the same household in south
gloucestershire a further investigation
is underway into a third case in england
the whereabouts of this person are
unknown
as they didn't complete their test
registration cards of the cases in
gloucestershire one of the affected
people returned from brazil to the uk
in mid-february but before the new hotel
quarantine measures were
introduced very pleased to say the
vaccines minister nadim zahawi joins us
once again on the program mr howie
always good to see you this morning um
and of course plenty to talk about in
terms of the brazilian variant but
you know we do like to mark the
milestones on this program and another
important one
has been passed 20 million people now
with the first
dose of the vaccine and some additional
funding to come
coming in soon to ensure that we get all
the way there to getting through the
adult population
or just as soon as possible really yes
uh neil it was an important moment on
sunday and i have to say
credit to the team who don't have a
sunday off
they don't have any day off they just
focus on continuing to deliver
the vaccination roll out where over 20
million
people with the first dose and we're
seeing good early
efficacy data in terms of both vaccines
and also of course good data from
scotland from public health scotland
in terms of both vaccines being
effective against
severe illness and hospitalization so we
keep going
we're focused on the next target which
is the
mid-april target to offer the vaccine to
32 million people cumulatively that is
everyone over the age of 50
and then we go on to offer the vaccine
to
all adults by the end of july and i'm
confident
with our supplies and the visibility of
deliveries that we will meet those
targets
can we though talk minister um about
this brazilian variant and just before
we get into the six cases that we have
identified here in the united kingdom
just how much do we know
about this variance of concern do we
have any indication
of what the effects of this variant are
in terms of transmissibility
in terms of well you just mentioned it
yourself vaccine
efficacy so in terms of its profile this
p1 variant is much closer to the south
african
variant which we've been dealing with
now uh for several weeks
by search testing genome sequencing and
isolation we've had a few hundred of the
south african variant and this variant
is a variant of concern it's very
similar in terms of
uh its mutations to the south africa to
the uh
south african variant so uh it is
concerning uh there is one case uh
who the individual didn't fill in their
test card details so we can contact them
if they you know they would probably got
a home kit or a test kit from their
local authority
and what we're asking today is anyone
had a test
on the 12th or 13th of february to
contact
nhs 119 so we make sure we identify that
individual and of course
the two cases of south gloucestershire
have been
isolating uh one traveled from south
sao paulo through zurich to london
before the hotel quarantine came in but
they did
take a pre-departure test and filled in
their forms the passenger locator form
which is why we're able to
deal with them so effectively and work
with south gloucestershire council
although there's minimal um reason to
believe that
there may be further spread because they
have been isolating correctly
but we will be doing a asymptomatic
testing
in south kostershire just in terms of
of the effect on on south
gloucestershire itself of course
big day next week in terms of you know
the schools fully reopening
we understand of course what can happen
if more transmissible variants
get into places which serve as vectors
for transmission
is there a possibility that in south
gloucestershire we might not see the
schools reopening on monday
so the way we've been dealing with the
south african variant
this will be very similar in the sense
that we search
test um and we rapidly
isolate and of course gene sequence
what we've done with schools is
delivered 50 million uh
lateral flow tests so that secondary
schools
and the teachers in those second schools
are tested twice a week
uh there are four tests for the students
as well
uh before uh they the the
um schools are um able to obviously
fully um uh bring children back to
schools and and all that
is taking place uh as we speak with
teachers and i want to just thank
obviously the teaching profession
they've been open all the way through
this second or you know this this spike
that we've had
since december um because they've been
teaching the frontline
uh healthcare staff children and those
children that are most vulnerable
and the work they're doing is is uh
incredibly important
and i'm confident that we'll get all
schools reopened on the 8th of march
sure but but just in terms of this
brazilian variant and the way in which
it got into the country
we have known about existence for quite
some time
we had advice from sage on the 21st of
january
that the only way to prevent new
variants from arriving here in the uk
was
was to quarantine all the rivals you
know the quarantine system didn't kick
in
until the 15th of february isn't it the
case
that if the government had been rather
quicker to introduce that scheme
we might not have seen the brazilian
variant in the community
well if you look at the two cases in
south gloucestershire
the case that came in from sao paulo
through zurich to
the united kingdom that case followed
exactly the correct procedure which is
the passenger locator form
a pre-departure test already conducted
and then isolated as well so the
uh regime for our borders is pretty
uh stringent uh there are other
countries and
we can sort of discuss say for example
um
australia who have even more stringent
border controls but they still have
um variants uh occurring and have to
deal with them and the way we've been
dealing with the south african
variance this was an indirect flight
wasn't it this was an indirect flight
and you know we've one warned up we've
been asking questions about on this
programme
a number of people in the conservative
benches the labour benches have been
warning about it as well
i mean as things stand people from
brazil can still get to this country
on an indirect flight so people from
brazil are banned
uh from coming to this country even if
it's on an indirect flight if they are
uk nationals or residents then they can
they have to fill in a
passenger locator form which this
individual did they have to take
a pre-departure test which this
individual did
they then have to isolate for ten days
and take two more tests
a test after two days and a test after
eight days
so three tests in total and i think that
system in itself is is robust which is
why we've been able to
locate uh these two cases and of course
the third is
is not linked uh to this but we
we need to identify them as which is why
if you've had a test on the 12th or the
13th
of february and haven't had your result
back please get in contact with nhs119
i suppose the problem with all of this
minister is you know people were warning
about the vague porous quality at our
borders we have the health secretary on
the program on the 4th of february
and i said this when we were still
didn't have a date for the quarantine
hotels
as things stand with the controls we
have at the border with no date for the
hotels isn't it the case
that there is a possibility a new
potentially dangerous variant
could arrive here in the united kingdom
bypassing all of the security you
mentioned mr hancock went on to say
you know we've got very stringent
measures in place the brazilian variant
got here
the stringent measures clearly weren't
enough
so when that was what i was really
trying to get at when i mentioned the
uh australian border uh protocols in
regime
or new zealand that people often quite
rightly refer to
as sort of your best examples of how to
do things
they still have uh challenge challenges
with variants
actually getting in and they still have
to surge
test do the genome sequencing
and isolate in the way we've been doing
with the south african variant
i think if you look at this case
actually if anything it says
that our border controls are pretty
robust because the individual
did have a pre-departure test they did
have the passenger locator form which is
why we were actually
still and we've still got one somewhere
potentially in the community yet to be
identified
yes and and that's why we need to make
sure we we
find that individual and we have
obviously um
data points that we're going to try and
make sure we we locate them and of
course
um the reason that we're asking the
media to help
is to if anyone has been tested on the
12th or 13th
of this month of february forgive me um
to come forward if they haven't had
their test results back because they the
one bit they didn't fill in
is their test card which has their
contact details
just in terms of what we're expecting
this week of course big week
for the chancellor and as always happens
you know we could spend you know 20
minutes speaking to you about
what's in the papers this morning and
we're all going to be told we have to
wait till wednesday so
just just philosophically as someone who
has a
keen interest in business what do you
want to see
from the chancellor this week i mean the
oas oecd
the world bank the imf all suggesting
that now is not the time for for tax
rises particularly on businesses
what's your view of that well i think
it's important uh
for all of us to wait uh it's only
another 48 hours
um till the chances are is on i'm on
tenterhook's minister come on
well look i can tell you one thing that
i know the chance has been telling
business quite rightly is that our
strategy
for the recovery uh from this
unprecedented
um challenger for the covert pandemic is
threated one
is infrastructure so a big focus on the
infrastructure bank and
investing you know big big amounts of
billions of pounds into infrastructure
especially green infrastructure the
prime minister
in his ten point plan set us a target
that by 2030
every home i will be powered by offshore
wind
so there's a big big push on
infrastructure the second is skills
and you look at the kickstart scheme 120
places have been created for those who
are probably most vulnerable to the
covert
challenge the youngest people uh who are
in the on the employment ladder getting
on it sure sure but
just in terms of the corporation tax
just in terms of the corporation tax and
i know you're not gonna answer this
specifically i know you're not to answer
this specifically
you get any number of companies at the
moment looking at whether or not to
relocate themselves
so that they have better access to the
eu market it's obviously happening
why would we give them another reason to
want to leave the country
in the form of a hiking corporation tax
well as i said look i can't comment on
uh any taxation
announcement as you can imagine uh not
least because they would be market
sensitive and of course
it's right that the chancellor delivers
his budget um as is traditionally done
uh on the third of march they're not
long to go
but what i would say is that this
country is eminently investible
you look at uh in terms of of uh
our skills base our knowledge base we've
demonstrated it obviously through the
uh discovery of the vaccines and i think
this is a great place
uh to come and invest which is why we
still attract you look at fintech
financial technology we still attract
more investment in this country i think
than
uh the whole of europe um uh does
in in in fintech or at least we're on
the top uh before someone calls me up on
at the top of the league
in terms of attracting uh fintech
investment to the united kingdom so i'm
i'm very confident that
uh as we come out of this covered
challenge uh
the economy will will bounce back and be
incredibly dynamic
not least helped by rishi sunax budget
on wednesday
uh minister we will speak again soon no
doubt thanks for being on the program
thank you very much uh well let's bring
in uh thomas murder science
correspondent who was listening
to our conversation with the vaccines
minister and appears to be a very dark
night uh wherever thomas moore is i'm
wondering if we still have him or if we
can perhaps
let's see we do have we do have him
indeed hi thomas morning
sorry about the technical issues uh what
did you think about what the minister
had to say
presumably not about the budget but
about the brazilian variant
yeah it's interesting that they're they
are reassuring people that uh we could
uh develop vaccines against this variant
but they are clearly trying to track
down this person they don't know their
whereabouts they don't know whether they
are self-isolating
and we know from uh previous cases of
the the south african variant
this has jumped from travelers into the
community and you heard there from the
minister there are now several hundred
of the south african
variants uh in in the uk and there will
be concern
that they want to stop this spreading
any further than it has
already and the reason is that if this
has some of the mutations from existing
variants so
the one that gives the transmissibility
to the uk variant
but also the one that helps the south
african variant to evade the immune
system
antibodies from vaccine and previous
infection and so on but it has one more
that isn't properly understood and that
is the big concern
about this this particular variant we
know in manas
three-quarters of people were immune to
to this uh to cover 19 and yet they had
such a dreadful surge in january that
hospitals were
running out of oxygen these were
re-infections
that underlines the concern about this
variant and why they're doing
everything to try and con identify
people who may be carrying it
thomas i will speak again during the
show i'm sure thanks very much
plenty coming on the show this morning
in fact uh starting with this a new type
of rapid test that will be on trial at
edinburgh airport we'll be finding out
how it works
at 20 past eight
i'll also be speaking to a father whose
son died on a nighttime three years ago
about the annual campaign established in
his memory based on random acts of
kindness that's at half past now
hello art lovers time for more studio
shenanigans
as another contestant gets to drop their
penny and pose on the podium
and at quarter to ten the comedian jenny
eclair joins us to discuss
turning 60 and her new life drawing
series
ah but ahead of all that it is the
interview that millions of royal
watchers
around the globe cannot wait to see now
a taster for harry and megan's big
interview with oprah winfrey has been
released
my biggest concern was history repeating
itself
almost unsurvived the prince gives
some of his reasons for stepping back
and says the process was
unbelievably tough you've said some
pretty shocking things here
these guys royal correspondent brianne
mills at joins us
on the programme morning rhiannon uh
what are we to make of it
are are you at the edge of your seat
already
i'm afraid i am um it's not surprising
that the producers of this interview
have
certainly gone for high drama when it
comes to
the promotional stuff that they're
putting out there and they have
literally
pulled out all the stops with this one
and one of the
one the promos you hear literally just
questions from oprah where she says to
megan
were you silent or silenced she also
talks about the fact that
when you say that it was unsurvivable it
sounds like there was some kind of
breaking point you don't actually hear
megan speak
but the allegations are there within
oprah's questions
we also hear from prince harry as well
making some very
damning claims about his family when it
comes to how his mother
was treated here's what he has to say
i'm just really relieved and happy to be
sitting here
talking to you with my wife by my side
because i can't begin to imagine what it
must have been like for her
going through this process by herself
all those years ago
because it has been unbelievably tough
for the two of us but at least we had
each other
and of course in the past we have heard
harry talk about
his concern that history was going to
repeat itself when it came to the way
that megan was being treated
um by the press but i think it is it's
quite shocking really to hear him
talking about his mother and also i
think making what seems to be quite
clear allegations about
his family members that they weren't
supportive of his mother we know that
prince harry and prince william have
always been
very careful when they've talked about
their mother's experiences
in the past also i think if we were
under any uh doubt as to whether or
whether harry and megan were going to be
subtle within this interview uh i think
that kind of clears all of that up they
certainly seem to be pulling
no punches and it is yeah still a week
to go and still until we hear that
interview
at this time next week we will have seen
it all and i suspect we will all be on
the edge of our seats
thanks randy let's take a look at a
couple of today's other main stories now
and myanmar's ousted leader onsang
tsuchi has appeared
via video link at a court hearing today
a month after the country's military
seized power
her lawyers say they've been unable to
see her despite requests to do so
it follows a weekend of violence in the
country which left
at least 18 dead
the defense secretary ben wallace says
the world continues to face the threat
of chemical weapons and warned that
people could learn to manufacture them
online
his warning comes almost three years
after the former russian spy sergei
skripal
was poisoned in salisbury with the nerve
agents novichok
and the governor of new york andrew
cuomo has acknowledged for the first
time that
some of his behavior with women may have
been misinterpreted as
unwanted flirtation he's facing two
accusations of sexual harassment
and says he will cooperate with an
independent investigation
led by the state's attorney general in a
statement he insisted he had never
inappropriately touched or propositioned
anyone
the crown was crowned the winner any
good nights
for the brits at the golden globe awards
but those awards shows are never
completely without controversy
even when they're virtual the british
actor sasha baron cohen
criticizing a lack of diversity in the
hollywood foreign press association
our entertainment correspondent lucy
cotter has the story
and the golden globe goes to
[Applause]
the crown british talent reigns supreme
in a ceremony which combined the
physical
and virtual with netflix show the crown
winning big at a time when tv has
dominated more than ever
respect for one another personally to
ask ourselves
some of the bigger questions stars
battled technology like we all have this
year to pick up awards
daniel kaluya judas and the black
most dressing for the occasion but
zooming in
from home alone love and appreciation
man god bless you lord yeah
i'm just gonna go i'm i'm at y'all alone
bro look at my i'm at the yard by myself
nobody to celebrate with i'm home alone
sasha baron cohen picked up two alluding
to the controversy surrounding this
year's globes
and although best director was awarded
to a woman for only the second time ever
there are no black members of the
hollywood forum press
you got to change that outrage over the
globe's lack of diversity
and alleged culture of corruption is
arguably what people are going to
remember
lucy cossa sky news
[Music]
uh time to see how the weather is
looking this monday morning nas has the
detail
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning today is the first day of
the meteorological spring and it does
look
fine for many areas it will feel
spring-like in the sunshine
and the largely dry conditions but not
everywhere we have got high pressure
dominating the scene once again so
generally speaking fine and settled for
this week
but there will be quite a bit of
moisture trapped under that uh around
central and eastern areas in particular
this morning there are fairly extensive
patches of mist and fog
and that may linger into this afternoon
across some eastern areas where it's
probably going to stay quite cloudy and
cold for
parts of yorkshire lincolnshire east
anglia the
midlands perhaps even towards eastern
parts of wales are the areas most prone
to it lingering and as you can see
temperatures will only be up into single
figures elsewhere we're looking at
highs into double figures once uh we see
any other
mist and fog patches lift and clear
there will be some good spells of
sunshine for ireland
northern ireland most of scotland most
of northwest england
and the majority of wales down towards
many southern counties of england as
well still a fairly keen easterly breeze
though down towards eastern areas so
perhaps a tad breezy there
but it will be mostly fine and mild as i
mentioned into tonight
mist fog and low cloud becomes fairly
extensive once again
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nice thank you coming up after the break
i'll be speaking to a doctor
about a campaign to halt what some
allege as the quiet privatisation of the
nhs
by foreign companies
it's all about numbers and boys we've
got some interesting ways of showing you
what's going on let's take a look at the
latest figures
most comprehensive ever assessment
latest analysis by sky news suggests
that's never happened before totally
unprecedented when you look at this
and all the other data you come to one
conclusion
[Music]
i think for those of us living with a
disability particularly progressive
disability because i'm deaf and going
blind due to usher syndrome
we already were faced with a series of
feeling quite isolated and
alone in that journey and for the
pandemic to come along and put extra
strain on that
there's certainly been very testing on
the mental health and i certainly didn't
feel i could go out and do my essential
shopping
as someone who is blind we can't
exercise a two meter rule my guide dog
doesn't understand the two meter rule
so what happened in effect as i
hibernated and i have been for the past
year
um i i've realized more than ever just
how much i really depended on my family
and friends to get me out
into society and to live an enjoyable
life um
but yeah so i can't say we're all alone
in that of course we've all we've all
struggled but i think people with
disabilities particularly
i think generally as as human nature
goes we tend to be quite selfish people
but i think in
in a sense we can hope that people can
be more empathetic towards people who do
live with everyday
isolation particularly those with usher
syndrome who have a progressive
condition
um you know i've lost the majority of my
vision already and got five degrees
vision and there's nothing that will
tell
me that i will lose the rest of that or
not so
it's it's very it's it's hard but i
think in a way
because everyone whether it's been just
situational depression but everyone has
struggled with their mental health
and so and every person with a
disability inevitably will struggle with
their mental health
so i do think that there will be some
level of empathy from the general
population towards people with
disabilities after pandemic
um whether or not that lasts i don't
know
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
we help you understand the world with us
stuart ramsey sky news
[Music]
welcome back uh time as always to take a
look at the latest coronavirus data for
the uk
six 635 new confirmed cases of covert 19
were recorded in the last
24 hours further 144 have died within 28
days
of testing positive bringing the uk
total to 122
849 meanwhile just over
20 million first doses of the vaccine
have been administered
but of course a hunt is now underway for
a person believed to be infected with
the brazilian variant of concern
after six cases were confirmed in the uk
in just the last few minutes the
vaccines minister
attempted to offer assurance that the
risk the variant is being spread in the
community
is considered low what we're asking
today is
anyone had a test on the 12th or 13th of
february to contact
nhs 119 so we make sure we identify that
individual and of course
the two cases of south gloucestershire
uh have been
isolating uh one traveled from south
power sao paulo through zurich
to london before the hotel quarantine
came in but they did
take a pre-departure test and filled in
their forms the passenger locator form
which is why we're able to
uh deal with them so effectively and
work with south gloucestershire council
although there's minimal um reason to
believe that
there may be further spread because they
have been isolating correctly
but we will be doing a asymptomatic
testing
in south gloucestershire and the
shadow secretary for working pensions
jonathan reynolds joins us once again on
the program mr reynolds good to see you
and of course a lot
around your brief to discuss ahead of
the budget on wednesday but can we talk
first and foremost about the the
brazilian variant which we now know is
is in the country six cases three in
scotland
at three in england what's the labour
view in all of this
is it the case that as mr zahavi was
telling me just a few minutes ago
actually the way in which they have been
able to identify and
and track five of the sex shows that the
system is working
well good morning now as you know in my
brief i focus very much on the jobs and
employment side
of this crisis but i'll tell you quite
honestly i do not understand
when i look at this crisis just what the
government strategy has been when it
comes to the borders
why the airports have been so lax
compared to what we all see
on television in other countries and i i
honestly don't know what the approach
has been on that at the beginning of the
crisis it was almost as if the
government was saying
there's no point in trying to put these
controls in place you know these strains
will move around
uh internationally and that's just
what's going to happen and we've got to
track them but
i'm surprised because it always seemed
to me well at least for the last
six months that the big danger has been
a mutant strain that our vaccine
rollout which is fantastic will not be
able to cope with so
for me i just don't understand why
there's been all of these delays and
getting a solid quarantine system in
place
well i don't want to put words into the
minister's mouth but it struck me that
the argument that he was deploying was
well look look at australia look at new
zealand far tougher controls at their
borders than we've had and they've had
them for a lot longer
and still variants of concern have
emerged there
well still i i look at it and i think if
you
look at a sensible strategy to controls
especially when test and trace
you know was not delivering the kind of
results that we all
knew it needed to be able to keep track
of those variants i mean obviously
i take a close look at the the test and
trace app in relation to the isolation
payments and things like that in my
brief and it
it would have been overwhelmed if it had
been trying to trace
new things coming in so i can't
understand it i think it has to have
been more robust on this
to me the absolute priority has to be
making sure we don't get these strains
in because yes we want to see
one tract when it's in the country but
of course the nightmare scenario would
be one
it does get out of control and puts us
further back and this is why there's
always been
not a trade-off to me between the
economic and health
side of this crisis you've got to look
at them together because if you get the
health measures wrong
the economic impact is even greater of
course the chancellor making his
statement at the dispatch box on
wednesday i wonder what you want to hear
from and and in particular what is the
labour party's position on corporation
tax
is any rights over the course of this
parliament something that you would
welcome
well what i want to see from the
chancellor on wednesday is an
unrelenting focus on jobs getting people
back to work i want this to be
the economic roadmap to recovery and i
want to see a lot more ambition from the
government particularly on employment
where
to be frankly government's employment
schemes like kickstart haven't delivered
yet
even if they delivered what the
government say they will it won't be
enough because already we know the
unemployment situation
is greater than the resources that have
been put towards that so we've got to
see more ambition we want to guarantee
for young people
in particular to say you've had a real
impact over this crisis
you will not be allowed to be out of
work for longer than six months we'll
get you education training
or a job that should be the the
guaranteed offer to young people
and on corporation tax now look i've
been on skype used many programs many
times
arguing that this country would be
better off with a a slightly higher rate
of corporation tax it would be
still a low level internationally and if
we use that money on better
infrastructure better skills
that would make us more competitive
overall and i still
believe that but would i put corporation
tax up in the middle of a crisis
arise if the papers are correct if the
leaks are correct the chancellor wanted
to go from 19
to 25 in one go would i do that in a
crisis
absolutely not because that would be
economically illiterate you've got to
have at this moment
everything focused on the recovery
everything focused on jobs
and that increases your tax base overall
and that is the way
you get back to a sustainable financial
position but to see an increase
overnight right now in a crisis of this
scale would be completely the wrong
position
all of which is why i was very careful
to frame my question in terms of
over the course of the parliament you're
certainly not ruling out corporation tax
rises
you wouldn't say that labour party
wouldn't want to see any uh rising
corporation tax
over the next four years it's just that
right now is not the point that you want
it to happen
yeah absolutely so if there's a schedule
set out by the chancellor
of course we will look at that but my
concern has always been i think many
colleagues is concerned has always been
that the chancellor might have been
looking perhaps not at what's right for
the economy but you know what's right in
political terms for himself and this
leak about trying to raise taxes in the
short term so he can say he's cut them
before
an election well that might work for him
but it wouldn't work for the british
economy right now
the focus has got to be on jobs getting
people back to work
and longer term that is how we get
control of the national finances and put
them into a sound position
but an overnight rise in the budget this
wednesday absolutely not that'll be
completely the wrong thing to do
if there's a wider schedule then of
course let's look at that over the
longer term
jonathan reynolds good to see you this
morning thanks for being with us thank
you
our political correspondent tom brainer
was listening to that interview
um and i suspect the chancellor might be
might be quite happy because the
suggestion in the papers this morning
appears to be yep there is a corporation
tax rise coming but it might be just a
little bit further down the line
yeah and politically it does put labour
in a slightly tricky position as
was illustrated by that interview
because jonathan reynolds saying
that he does believe that longer term
increasing corporation tax would be a
good thing for the country
but just not right now and um basically
putting forward an argument
in response from the opposition of just
not right now
is a tricky one it's a tricky line to
walk what labour wants
to say on this is that the focus has to
be that rel unrelenting
uh focus on jobs and on protecting the
economy in that
taxes is not what they need to see right
now but clearly
labour ultimately want to see the tax
taxes increase to support the state so
it's a tricky balance and you can see
that i think in that interview i think
you can
tom thanks very much indeed uh now a
coalition of doctors and campaigners
have written a letter
urging the health secretary to
investigate claims of privatization
of the nhs by stealth by a u.s company
the group
keep our nhs public are campaigning
against the merger of the uk's biggest
gp practice operator with u.s health
insurance
group sentine corporation which is set
to have 58 practices under its watch
i will let's speak now uh to the gp and
chair of doctors in unite dr jackie
appleby
who's joining us now dr napoli lovely to
have you on the programme
this morning um just how much of an
issue
is this how much of our health services
currently uh being parcelled up and and
sold off in your view
it's a massive massive issue and it's
been going on under the radar for years
and years and we're always told
um that the nhs isn't being privatized
but this is more evidence that in fact
it is um
and this you know a us massive giant us
health corporation have got their feet
now
under the table of um uk general
practice
and what this means is that unlike um
your traditional gp we all
are funded we get a fixed budget to
provide services
um and we invest all of that money into
our services and so gp's effectively
paying themselves a salary out of that
fixed budget
but organizations like this they have
shareholders they have to
generate a profit to provide dividends
to their shareholders
the only way you can do that from
general practice is by cutting costs
so cutting costs involves cutting staff
costs
so increasing skill mix having less
doctors
um and this then knocks on to services
for patients
so it's it's a really big problem i
think during covid as well and we've
seen how
um contracts go to private companies for
things like ppe
um with with very little scrutiny and i
really worry that with the new um leaked
white paper
um that they say that competition will
be a thing of the past in the nhs which
would be great if the nhs was the
provider
but if um the contracts are going to go
without scrutiny to
um private companies such as centene
um we will be sort of down the spiral
into a u.s healthcare system
uh yeah doctor just just on that point i
mean clearly
a lot of people have become focused on
this particular issue because of
sentient links to uh us healthcare and
u.s health insurance but actually i mean
80 media
sorry at medics the company which with
the organization which they are taking
over
made 35 million pounds in profit
over the last five years and this is a
company that was set up by
six nhs gps 37 gp
practices across 49 sites in london i
mean even without
the influence of american healthcare
companies
this is something that people will be
both surprised and shocked about i'd say
yes and that's on all those millions are
millions that are not being invested in
patient care and they should be being
invested in patient care
and the nhs belongs to the people um and
it was brought in in place of fear in
1948 so that people could get the care
they needed when they needed it
and if millions of pounds are being
siphoned off in into the pockets
of of individuals and into shareholders
and it's absolutely shocking
um i mean in the general practice where
i work all of the fixed budget that we
are provided with goes into providing um
patient services and this is exactly how
it should be
and dr appleby just before we run out of
time as we often do on this program
how are you and all of your colleagues
doing at the practice at the moment
we're okay thank you i mean we are you
know it's hard it's tough
it's a huge logistical challenge but
we're getting the vaccine rolled out
and um you know we're hopeful that um
even with the variance this is going to
make make a big difference
thank you well keep up the good work uh
dr raphael thanks so much for joining us
in the program
thank you still to come on the programme
uh this morning from champions to
non-existence overnight no nothing about
celtic
instead a curious tale from the world of
chinese football
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do
they say they'll be killed
[Applause]
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
[Music]
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside it means pressure
day
can't access those and needs
you can see the depth of water if you
have a look in front of us
there are people wading through it
[Music]
i think experiencing the two million
person march in hong kong
that was a moment i don't like the
chinese government it's true
[Music]
it was real people power in action
police have been firing tear gas and
rubber bullets
see fires all around us here and just
one of them is the size of around 31 000
football pitches siobhan robbins
sky news bangkok
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertaining
podcast
for wherever you are welcome to safety
rage what's the day podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners from sky news story
cast
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know that reducing
pollution outside of school
can help stop toxic air getting trapped
in our classrooms
most places will be dry today with
bright or sunny spells
except across central and eastern parts
of england and wales
where missed fog and low cloud will
linger
so taking a look at the air pollution
levels today on a scale of 1 to 10 with
10 being very high
many areas will be at a low level 1 to
3.
however there is a chance of some
pockets of moderate air pollution
at levels 4 to 6 mainly across eastern
areas where the fog
lingers today the air quality report
sponsored by philips air purifiers
all right let's conclude there with a
bit of a thought experiment imagine if
your football team
had won the league fulfilling all the
fans wildest dreams
but then inexplicably disbanded
overnight well that's what's happened in
china
the super league winners zhang sufc have
announced that the club has
ceased all operations uh with immediate
effect
what on earth is going on there uh well
joining us now daddy raftinson
uh former assistant coach to the jiangsu
uh women's team uh
and clearly we'll have a view in all of
this uh daddy thank you so much for
joining us in the programme
this morning and you know we've had any
number of problems uh financial problems
club big clubs with financial problems
here
but winning and then going out of
business overnight i mean that's quite
something tell us exactly what's
happening to you
yeah so you learn you learn quickly in
china football that um
nothing can come as a surprise anymore
but um
what has happened this has nothing to do
with football so
in china football is not grassroots or
bottom up like it's normally is in
europe it's
it's a top-down affair so
big corporations like sooning which is
one of the biggest companies in china
they operate these clubs sort of at the
you know
goodwill of the government of the local
government
and what's happened is that the
corporation has run into
that repayment problems and they have to
get rid of you know what they don't
consider as core business which
uh football isn't it's sort of like a
mix of walmart amazon
paypal you know they have a cell phone
operators so it's a it's a huge company
that is now running it into problems
that has nothing to do with football and
this is what
what they've come up with i i i have to
ask then i wonder what what the players
both men and women what the what the
prospect is for them of having
you know a career with the club
so i've actually heard from a couple of
players both side and
uh you know it's come obviously as a
shock so
you know most of them will be looking
for new clubs
um but what will probably happen is that
um
like normally in china somebody else
will take over the operations
but it's the same with suning because
they've
invested a lot in the in in football in
jiangsu and and jiangsu is actually a
traditional chinese football powerhouse
so they've actually run you know pretty
impressive ship
it was very professional to work for
them and a lot of you know professional
people who were
running the organization so they had a
huge youth program they had uh one of
the
you know best funded women's teams in
the world when i was over there and
they've actually won the title in 2019
so um somebody else will take over but
you know
it remains to be seen if they can
continue at the same level of operations
there is a connection with uh with enter
isn't there with inter milan
any prospect that that might serve as
something of a lifeline or is it just as
you say that it's
it's likely that we're just going to see
some other corporate conglomerate coming
in
and and taking straight over
well that's the news from italy is that
uh
they have been re seeking investment for
the
inter part of the business and uh
that's actually like a duel in a crown
and um
and something that they would probably
want to keep a hold of
but uh if they can't finance the
operations they'll probably
be you know looking to get in new
investors or or sell it off
daddy clearly china is a huge market for
for football the domestic consumption of
course
but also you know football overseas
being being shown
being shown there is there any risk that
the collapse of jiangsu
puts at risk you know domestic football
in china it strikes me probably not just
because they've got quite a lot of
people
and quite a lot of money
yeah i you know like i said earlier you
know nothing comes as a surprise so
you know they'd probably be up and
running in in in a different form
uh sooner than you'd think but uh
chinese football has changed a lot in
the last 10 years so
china is trying to build football from
from the you know from the grassroots or
not up to the professional clubs to be
able to compete on the
global level so it's not it's
it's a combination of being a business
venture as well as being a political
venture because
china wants to use football to show that
you know when when they're able to have
success at the highest level in the
world cup or players in europe
that they will be you know it's a
geopolitical issue so they
it's it's an issue of arriving on the
world states
so they will figure it out somehow i'm
i'm quite sure of that
um and of course at some point in the
future china clearly wants to be done
well
china wants to dominate in pretty much
everything but
in terms of football might just be a
couple of years yet before the top of
the fifa rankings
yeah at least a couple of years and and
maybe even a couple of decades but um
the speed of everything and and and you
know when they get into
you know when they get into it they
they do it quickly and they do it
impressively but it might take a couple
of times to get where they want to be
exactly mine uh data raffin great to
have you in the program this morning
thanks for being with us
thank you time for us let's have a look
at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning today is the first day of
the meteorological spring
and it does look like it is going to be
a spring-like day for many areas and
that's thanks to high pressure keeping
it
fine still and in fact for much of this
week but
nights will be chilly there will be
frosts and there will be some fog as
well in fact this morning
there's frosty conditions across many
northern and western areas with a few
patches of mist and fog but the fog
is really quite extensive across many
parts of england and
wales particularly dense across some
eastern areas parts of
lincolnshire yorkshire the east midlands
seen visibility down to around 50 meters
and most of the mist and fog will lift
and clear but some of it
is likely to linger i think into this
afternoon particularly those
areas i mentioned around areas of east
anglia as well so
as a result many central eastern parts
will still remain quite
dull this afternoon and feeling quite
cold as a result with that lack of
sunshine
elsewhere there will be bright or sunny
spells developing for most of ireland
northern ireland the majority of
scotland north west england
most of wales and southern counties of
england a bit breezy still across the
south particularly along the south coast
perhaps making it feel
a little cooler but it will still be
mild for many areas in the sunshine
again tonight
we see the return of mist and fog
the weather sponsored by qatar airways